uh open this hearing
by reading the required
information about us being able to meet
on zoom
as chair of division two of the house
finance committee
i find that due to the state of
emergency declared by the governor
as a result of the coba covet 19
pandemic
and in accordance with house rule 67
and the governor's emergency order
number 12
pursuant to executive order
2020-04 this public
body is authorized to meet
electronically
this public meeting is pertaining to
transportation and safety
going through their presentations
please note that there is no physical
location for members of the public to
observe
and listen contemporaneously to this
meeting
however in accordance with emergency
order
i am confirming that all members of the
committee
and select legislative staff have the
ability to communicate
contemporaneously during this meeting
through the zoom
electronic meeting platform and public
access to contemporaneously listen
and if necessary participate in this
meeting
by the zoom platform or by telephone
all necessary access information has
been made available
in the house calendar and through the
electronic calendar
on the general court website the notice
for this meeting complies with house
rules
and rsa 91a
anyone who has a problem accessing the
meeting
should email lba underscore
fiscal at leg dot state
dot nh dot us in the event the public is
unable to access the meeting the meeting
will be adjourned and rescheduled
lba staff are on the meeting assisting
us
please note that all votes that are
taken during this meeting
shall be done by roll call vote let's
start the meeting by taking a roll call
attendance with when each member states
their presence
please also state whether there is
anyone in the room with you
during this meeting which is required
under
the right to know law representative
lynn
are you here i am yes can you hear me
yeah would you call rick please i will i
will
yes uh representative bucco
uh yes thank you i i'm um i'm president
i'm at home in conway and there's no one
else in the in the
in the room all right uh representative
danielson
is not here that's great uh
representative heath
mary heath um i'm here at my home in
manchester
new hampshire and um my husband is in
the other room
all right and representative lynn i'm
here obviously
representative murray good morning kate
murray is here in newcastle that was my
barky dog asking to go out my husband
has taken them out they'll both be
back in shortly doug will stay here
husband will head back down to the
basement
thank you representative petry
representative petrie's here in
farmington there's a dog and a wife
roaming around the halls
thank you and representative umberger
yes i'm at my home in
kearsarge new hampshire my husband my
husband's in the house someplace
i don't know where i'm sorry i should
say i'm i'm uh
i'm in the room i'm at home i'm in the
room alone my wife and son are elsewhere
in the house
okay so mickey would you please
uh uh bring up
uh commissioner sheehan
if she's not already here
good morning madam chair members of the
committee i'm victoria sheehan the
commissioner for dot
it's my pleasure to be with you all
today and thank you for this opportunity
to talk about
our budget and the others on the
this morning are bill cass our assistant
commissioner
chris wozchuck our deputy commissioner
marie mullen is our director of finance
and kathy mulhey hampson who should be
on here as well i don't see marie maybe
she hasn't been promoted yet
no she just joined uh and i'm gonna pull
her in now
so marie will be the one sharing her
screen and showing the presentation
are you sharing or do you want me to
commissioner marie would you share
please
or would you like i i have it right up
so okay maybe do i have permission to
share
you should be able to marie i don't know
if it's given you there you go
how's that great
okay well this morning we're going to
begin
by giving you an overview of the
department and
providing you with
some information on our roles and
responsibilities
in addition to the presentation that we
prepared for today
we did prepare a budget book and for
those of you that are returning to this
committee
you'll recall that we've done this for
past budgets
and that document was provided to mickey
and i believe
was posted we'll be printing hard copies
and we'll make sure that you get those
but we want to ensure that you're aware
of the digital version that has been
provided that document is a great tool
for you all
um for each of our different accounting
units and bureaus
we have a description of
the work that each of those sections
completes each year
um with some actual metrics around
what can be accomplished with the
dollars that are provided
as well as information on how many
full-time employees we have supporting
that area of the department
um so we won't walk through that budget
book today
in detail and we'll start with this high
level
overview presentation but we look
forward to working with the committee
and coming back to provide any
additional information
that you might need from us as you work
on
the budget for 22 and 23. the other
document that we'll be mailing out with
the budget books
is our factbook um while we
you know are going to be working with
you on the budget itself and we
recognize that there might be other
questions that you have you know maybe
questions on projects in your region of
the state
or specific questions about our
operations
and so we have a fact book that we
prepare at the start of every
um legislative session so that
most importantly you have contact
information for everyone at the vot
and can get answers to questions as they
arise
um so look out for the hard copies of
both the budget book and our factbook
but this morning we're going to walk you
through a presentation you're going to
be hearing from myself
from bill cass chris wojcick and marie
we have plenty of time and so
we'd like to be able to address your
questions as we go through the slides
um so please stop us at any time and um
if you're ready madam chair we'll begin
i'm ready i was on mute sorry thank you
please okay um so most importantly our
mission here at dot is
to provide transportation excellence
enhancing the quality of life in new
hampshire
we are very aware that the work that we
do
each and every day significantly impacts
every person traveling through new
hampshire
and every one of our residents but most
importantly
we're in the business of meeting of
moving people and goods which directly
impacts the state's economy
and so we are trying to provide
a safe reliable and well-maintained
system
and so that everyone can get where they
need to go and that goods and services
can be delivered
and we work very diligently to stretch
the value of the dollars that were
provided to deliver on this mission and
purpose
next slide
so just so you understand how
our org chart looks um so we have three
commissioners
myself and bill cass as assistant
commissioner and chief engineer
oversees all things highway and that
includes the division of project
development and the division of
operations
and then chris washcheck as our deputy
commissioner
oversees our other three divisions
finance
policy administration as well as
aeronautics rail and transit
this particular representation of
our department makes it look like we're
quite
siloed but in reality we're a very flat
organization
and so for example the bureau of
environment is
under the division of project
development but they support the entire
department
um even on occasion aeronautics rail and
transit
as necessary so while we have technical
disciplines
located within one division there are
resources being brought to bear
across all of our different programs and
work effort
next slide
so how do we manage all of this work um
so in addition to the three
commissioners
we have a director for each of the
divisions and then for the larger
divisions of project development and
operations
we also have an assistant director
providing support
in each of those areas and perhaps the
most important piece of information
today is the phone number on the screen
that is the front office direct line so
anytime you have questions for
commissioners or directors
please use that number and we are here
to help
and kathy is also on today because she
acts as our
legislative liaison and so if for any
reason
you're looking for information and it's
particularly time sensitive
you can always reach out to kathy
directly and she will
collect the information from the
responsible party here at d.o.t
next slide
um so just to give you a sense of um
how big our agency is and what our
responsibilities are
we have around 1650 full-time employees
in addition we have a number of both
part-time as well as seasonal employees
and for example in the bureau of
turnpikes many of our toll-taker
positions are part-time positions
and then because of the nature of our
work
we do hire seasonal employees either for
the winter season
or for the summer construction season
depending on the area
and the programs that we are responsible
for
on the highway side of the house we have
2160 state bridges that we're
responsible for
one of the statistics that's always of
interest to the legislature
is how many of those bridges are on what
we in new hampshire call the red list
the red list is really
a list of all of the bridges that are
considered structurally deficient in the
state
in other words structures that are in a
poor or very poor condition
um they are they are safe we inspect
them much more frequently
we actually go out there every six
months to check them rather than every
two years
but those are bridges that are reaching
the end of
their useful life and need either
significant
rehab or replacement so
this is a number that we always pay
close attention to
so as we work on the budget we'll be
talking about
the condition of the infrastructure and
then the
funding as well as the personnel needed
to continue to
address both our bridges and our
payments
excuse me uh commissioner if i could
uh are your 650 employees
is that the authorized number of
employees or is that what you actually
have on the end
that is the authorized number of
positions um later on we'll talk about
one of our challenges
last year with the budget or sorry with
the funding uncertainty
and revenue impacts of covet 19
the governor implemented a hiring freeze
and we do have a very high vacancy rate
at this time
that we're working to address but we'll
talk about that in more detail
later in the presentation okay i just
wanted to be sure that was authorized
yes okay thank you and then in addition
to our state-owned assets we also are
responsible for inspecting
all of the municipal bridges in the
state of which there's around 1690.
um we are not responsible for the work
that's performed on
those structures but we do inspect them
and work closely with the towns
to make them aware of any issues that
there might be
next slide
and then on the highway side we're
responsible for approximately 4 600
center lane miles of roadway
most of that roadway is both summer and
winter maintained by the department um
but there is approximately 300 miles
that are owned by dot and town
maintained
and with um this number of miles
of highway every year we're striving to
pave around 550 center lane miles
that's what's required to keep our
pavement infrastructure in a good state
of repair
and we'll talk a little bit more about
this number as well as we move through
the presentation
but we're not just responsible for
bridges and pavements there's
countless other roadside assets out
there
from all of our highway signs to our
guard rail
um every year we have to strike the
roadways
and then of course there's all the
traffic signals and
other devices along our highways as well
so we have been working to build up
inventories in all of these areas
and then not on the screen and obviously
there are pipes
culverts and closed drainage systems as
well as sidewalks and crosswalks and
other assets that we're responsible for
and then we are multimodal dot as i
mentioned we have a division of
aeronautics rail and transit
while we don't operate um air rail or
bus service as a dot
um we do work very closely with of the
providers of those services
in the state um so there's 195 miles of
active state-owned rail line as well as
public access airports in the state and
11 public transit systems that we
partner with
and we'll talk about that in a little
bit more detail in a few minutes
next slide um so at this point i'm going
to turn it over to chris wojcik
who will give you a high level overview
of the budget
and then as the presentation progresses
we'll do a deeper dive
so chris good morning members of the
committee
um so this slide with this shows
is uh fiscal year 20 20
actual expenditures um
which were much lower than the budget
and we the actual expenses were 681
million
um on the municipal aid and construction
side 419 million and on the operating
side 262 million so
for example aid that will include block
granted
um passed which is a direct pass-through
from our budget to the municipalities uh
it also includes
uh indirect um technical and program
assistance
such as the tap program um construction
costs primarily consist of
projects that are in the 10-year plan
the department progresses
on the operating side uh basically those
costs are
cost for the requirement to maintain and
operate
the current infrastructure um as well as
to plan engineer and oversee the
construction program
you can see the breakup um
primarily two thirds
is uh municipalities of construction
um and then the rest for the operating
as you can see
um the entire budget is a makeup of
highway fund which is 36 percent
the federal program federal funds which
flow through
the highway fund um 35
the turnpike uh funds 19
other which may be non-budgeted
expenditures such as
tiffia and bonded capital projects those
those are the other and then um general
fund is
the one percent uh next slide
this is kind of the history of
authorized full-time positions
um on the previous slide commissioner
reported that 1650
were our current level of authorized
positions you can see that
has been the case in the current
biennium and then that is the case
moving forward
we're not adding any additional
positions
but one thing i want to note here is
that
our authorized positions have fallen
dramatically
uh since 2010. you can see
that in 2010 we had over 1828 positions
and we're roughly 178 fewer positions
today and we have been at that level for
quite some time
um in addition to that i just want to
point out
that we have a 15
vacancy rate right now um
so we have 241 vacant positions and we
are working
actively to fill those uh the department
has been
in a really um challenged
um with the hiring freeze and being able
to keep up with
um all the work so we are we are moving
forward to uh phil
uh with the hiring freeze being lifted
can you repeat the vacancy rate uh
15 a little over 15
241 vacant positions um at this time
next slide
so here's the funding summary for um
uh budget or the governor's recommended
budget
on fiscal year 22 it's 674 million
uh municipal aid and construction 354
million
operating 320 million um
and then in fiscal year 23 um
684 million on the municipality of
construction 350
and operating uh 334 i do want to point
out that
um when i did present fiscal year 20
the operating side was considerably
lower and that's because of
when covet hit you know we really uh
tightened our tightened up belt i would
say
and only um expended uh absolutely
necessary
um you know budget and um
we had a very very high lapse in fiscal
year 20
because of the impacts on covert
and um the need to really watch
how much was spent a lot of things in
that year
did not get done you know so this
is a budget that you know really
you know tries to do all the necessary
things that the department is
responsible for in
in order to operate and maintain the
system
as well as progress the projects in a
10-year plan
next slide
so this is just a makeup um and it shows
fy 20 actuals uh the fy20 adjusted
authorized um
our agency budget and governor's budget
present um
proposals for 22 as well as 23.
um and you can see the light blue is
federal
uh so you can see federal is pretty um
[Music]
pretty stable at the roughly a little
over 200 million
level with the exception of fiscal year
that jumps up to 248 million excuse me
and the reason for that is
with the covert relief
where new hampshire is receiving 41
million dollars
um and we're putting that right into the
budget
to offset the revenue loss so you can
see there's a considerable jump in
fiscal year 22
um from what we presented um
at the 207 million to 248 million that's
the 41 million of
cobit relief funds from the federal
government um
so perhaps chris if you don't mind we'll
pause for a second to explain what
relief dollars transportation has
received
so when the cares act was passed there
was
direct assistance provided
to aeronautics and to
public transportation but in that first
package there was
nothing specifically dedicated to
highway uses
later on when subsequent relief packages
were passed including the
package that was approved by congress at
the end
of calendar year 2020 then there was
additional
monies provided once again for airports
and for public transportation
but that last relief bill also provided
the 41
million for highways to address lost
revenue so that's what chris is
referring to
in addition the department has been
supporting some of the statewide
response to covet 19
performing tasks that don't pertain
directly to transportation but doing our
part to support the governor and other
agencies
and so we have also been reimbursed with
either fema dollars or shall be
reimbursed in the future for the work
that we're performing currently
or we did receive some of the gopher
relief funds as well
um so i just wanted to make sure that
you weren't thinking it was all coming
from one pot
we actually did receive dedicated funds
in
the cares act and then in the subsequent
relief bill
we're not talking about the 1.25 billion
of gopher funds
although dot did have access to that as
well sorry chris
no thank you for that commissioner um
that helps explain
that funding much better you can see
other funding um levels are pretty
pretty stable at around that low
80 million dollar range general funds
which basically fund our um aeronautics
rail and transit bureaus
uh they are very stable at that 1.3 to
1.6 million dollar level
um little general funds flow into
the department on the highway side um
i noted that the actuals were
you know considerably low in fiscal year
20. um on the highway side we
expended 194 million that yet because of
you know the department's diligent and
really uh watching how
highway funds were being expended um in
fiscal year 21
uh the budgeted level was 230 million
and you can see
um in the 22 and 23
budgets we're slightly below that
i'm in 22 and right about that with the
governor's budget in 23.
um and then the turnpike side is fairly
uh stable at the um
at that 157 million dollar range
and now talk about the turnpike um in a
few moments but that
does include both operating and capital
work
um on the turnpike side the turnpike
system also took a hit in 2012 uh fiscal
year 20 due to covert
so you can see the expenditures were
dramatically lower
um on the turnpike side as well
any questions before i move on
okay next slide marie
and i'll turn this over to the
commissioner to talk about um
these next two slides
yes absolutely um what how much was the
labs
please um
our laps was 37 million dollars last
year
obviously that's not sustainable we feel
uh there were a lot of
um new programs that were budgeted
uh for preventative maintenance and
equipment that we were not
able to purchase and that's was a reason
why there was such a significant lapse
later in the presentation we'll talk
about the issues and challenges and
talk a little bit more about where we
lapsed the dollars
last year if i made that lapse was
only on the highway side that 37 million
the marine noted
is only in highway funds the turnpike
system also lapsed
a considerable dollar value i don't have
it right in front of me but
um it was close to 10 million
yeah and i'll just say that's d.o.t not
that does not include safety's laps
so we'll start by talking about the
general fund
um since we used so few general fund
dollars um well we'll go from smallest
to largest program
and talk about the highway fund
last and so a little bit of a deeper
dive on
the bureaus of aeronautics rail and
transit
as i mentioned we work closely with all
of the public use airports
we inspect the airports and
many of those that qualify for federal
funds those federal dollars
flow through the department as well so
there are three commercial airports in
new hampshire
manchester lebanon and peace and so we
work closely with those three commercial
airports
but then there's what we call block
grand airports and that's the other
nine airport that are eligible for
federal funds
unfortunately there's some smaller
airports that do not receive federal aid
and we provide some assistance to those
airports
with the revenues that we collect from
aircraft registration
and the department is responsible for
registering
all aircraft in the state and so while
we
have less day-to-day operational
responsibilities at the airports
we are very much working hand-in-hand
with them and advocating on their behalf
on the rail side i mentioned before that
we have
active state-owned track in new
hampshire so we have 195 miles of
active track that the d.o.t owns
and we have six operating agreements uh
with four freight
providers and two tourist services that
run on those corridors in addition
there's about 340 miles of
inactive corridor which
we oversee
and coordinate the management of many of
these corridors are being used for
rail trails as an interim use and we
partner with the department of natural
and cultural resources
specifically the bureau of trails who
have some of the day-to-day management
responsibilities
for these sections and then lastly on
the public transit side
there are 11 local public transit
systems that we work with
in addition we do coordinate with all of
the private bus
operators in new hampshire and then
lastly we operate our own intercity
commuter service called the boston
express
there is an operating agreement with
concrete coach who provides that service
for us
but it is a state funded service
but beyond the the fixed route services
um that our
our transit systems provide um we're
also
responsible for the allocation of
federal transit dollars to community
transportation providers and
specifically
human service and volunteer driver
programs that are serving
primarily you know seniors and
individuals with disabilities
so we have a lot of different types of
federal funding that come from the
federal transit administration with very
strict parameters in how we can spend
that
um from the dollars that are committed
to our smaller urban
systems to dollars that go to rural
transportation
and then lastly the human service
and volunteer driver programs excuse me
commissioner
did you say that d.o.t runs the boston
express
yep that's a state-owned service that is
operated
by concord coach contract with us
is that profitable or do they conquer
coach
pro gives you money and
um so pre-pandemic this was one of the
most successful bus
services in the country we
started to provide this service as one
of our commitments
as we advanced the widening of i-93 from
salem to manchester
and um we have seen
great ridership pre-pandemic with um
record numbers uh riding specifically on
the fb everett route 3 corridor
and um i would say
that service had been thriving and
obviously since the pandemic
uh with the reduction in commuter
traffic um
you know we are trying to project what
the future holds
for all of our um inter-city and
commuter bus services
because certainly we're not seeing the
ridership that we were previously with
so many people continuing to telework
um and not drive down to the city as
often
there's also folks who would go down to
boston for medical appointments as an
example that rely heavily
on this service as well as individuals
who were flying from logan airport
who rely on these services to get to the
city
and a lot of
the customers just haven't come back yet
because
telemedicine is still being used and
vacation
travel is still significantly limited
thank you very much next slide please
marie
um so the uh
the general funds that we're allocated
are primarily
going to fund the aeronautics bureau and
the railroad bureau
the transit bureau is primarily funded
with federal funds
and earlier i mentioned that we received
assistance through the cares act
and usually we have to come up with
the match for both operating and capital
purchases on our transit systems
but a lot of the cares act provisions
have allowed us to
access 100 federal funding and
that certainly um reduces
uh the burden on municipalities and
others who
um were struggling to come up with the
match to access some of those federal
dollars
so our budget currently includes two
hundred thousand per year of general
funds for transit operating
match um to access those federal dollars
so our budget's very small on the
general fund side for 2022
it's 1.5 million and for 2023
it's 1.6 million um we only had
one additional need in our agency phase
um
and that was actually funded by the
governor in his
phase uh during the last budget we had
requested a new position
um an aeronautics uh planning position
obviously um what we call uas's
or what people not commonly referred to
as drones
is an industry that's expanding very
rapidly
and so um during the last budget we
advocated for a position that could be
dedicated
to working through some of the
challenges with
the increase in the number of drones
operating in the state
that position was funded in the last
budget but
because of the covet
challenges we did not move forward with
filling it and so that position
is included in the governor's budget and
we're hoping to move forward with
filling that vacancy
and now that there is more certainty
around future revenues
and so that really is all of our
information to share on the general fund
side
and we'd be happy to answer any
remaining questions or
if you specifically would like more
information
on the various services that are
provided
or have questions about aeronautics
rail or transit funding that we receive
from the federal government
and we'd be happy to get that for you
all right i'm hearing none so i think i
don't i don't see any hands raised
okay so i'll turn it back to chris and
he'll talk about the turnpike system in
a little bit more detail
hello again so just to give you a brief
overview of
the turnpike system in you know where
it's located basically in the
southeastern part of the state
um on the the turnpike system is really
made up of three turnpike segments
the central turnpike extends from the
state line in nashua
all the way up to exit 14 in concord
so it it runs along uh route 3 of the
ffe everett
from nashua through through merrimack
through bedford
it's co-joined with 293 through
manchester and then
um and then meets up with 93 through the
hooks of toll plaza
and then like i said ends at exit 14 in
concord
um on the eastern side we have both the
blue star
which runs from state line to state line
on i-95
and then the spaulding which runs from
the portsmouth traffic circle
um all the way up to
exit 18 in milton so it's 89 miles long
in total
172 bridges uh eight toll facilities
um it is an enterprise fund so for
example
all the turnpike revenue that's
collected on the turnpike system must be
used on the turnpike it cannot be used
for any other purpose turnpike revenue
pays for operation
and maintenance on the system any debt
service
that exists on the current outstanding
bonds
that we use to build portions of the
system are in our work which is in
essence
work that is done to make sure the
system's in
good working order that work entails
paving uh drainage guardrail some bridge
preservation work
and then lastly it flows down to the
capital program
uh such as you know the major projects
that we have
underway in the 10-year plan and the
effie ever widening
manchester exit six and the bull
concrete project just recently
uh the newington dover project on the
spa then got completed
so that's basically what the capital
improvements entail
and all that is including the 10-year
plan
in fiscal year 20 there were 110 million
transactions
um with the total revenue of 131 million
um just for comparison purposes
uh we use fiscal year 19 kind of to
compare
from the you know kind of pre-covert to
post covert effect
so in fiscal year 19 we had 123.7
million transactions so in fiscal year
those 11 field transactions
um next slide
so this kind of shows um over the last
10 years going back to
fiscal year 2010 kind of what the fund
history
for tow revenue looks like and you can
see
it's fairly flat in 2010 11 through
14 at about that 117 million
then it started to rise uh in fiscal
year 19 it kind of peaked
um at 145 million of toll revenue
an additional 8.7 million of other
revenue which
consists of interests we have
a build america bond subsidy uh hooksett
uh welcome center revenue things like
that um and then
um covet hit and it has had a huge
impact
on the system um fiscally at
20 um revenues down about
uh 11 from fiscal year 19.
uh fiscal year 21 we're forecasting
we're going to end up at about 17
lower than fiscal year 19 and then it's
going to start
improving um but feels good yet 22 and
23 we're still going to be down
13 and 9 below fiscal year 19 high
so that just kind of gives you a
snapshot of
what's happening on the turnpike system
next slide please
so here we've been able to track
the impact that covert has had on
traffic this is
this is a counter actually that it's an
automated counter that we have
in conquered on i-93 between exits 12
and 13.
uh you can see and and i do want to say
that
this shape of a graph
is very similar to what's happening on
the turnpike system
precovered back last february
in 2020 traffic was slightly higher than
the previous
year and this gives you a comparison of
the current year uh to the previous
years
same week traffic when covert hit
traffic dropped
dramatically at this counter dropped
down to 50 percent
below the previous year's level um
that was back at the end of march uh
first week in april of last year and
then it started climbing back up
as things opened up a little bit
uh in the summertime in june and july
traffic was roughly between 14
um i would say 12 to 14 below the
previous year
and then that kind of existed through
the summer
into the early fall and then again we're
now seeing traffic
settling at about uh 18 to 20
below last year's levels now certainly
up in the north country in the western
part of the state i think traffic
um although it has a similar shape has
not been
as significant in terms of
reduction um the north country and
western part of the state may be seeing
traffic at about 10
15 lower uh than previous year whereas
again this is at about 18 to 20 percent
lower
on the turnpike system traffic uh the
low
peaked at 58 um
below the previous year's level that
again was at the end of march early
april
and right now we're seeing traffic right
around the 20
uh below last year's level so
very significant impact on revenue next
slide
so on the turnpikes um what we do is we
have
a model which helps us
with a 10-year plan
as well as we take a look at what we
need for operation and maintenance
and covert has had a huge impact um on
the turnpike system
so we do have a consultant
that does uh traffic and revenue
forecasting
um they do investment grades so for
example
if the turnpike system goes uh to secure
additional bonding um investment grade
traffic and revenue information is
necessary so this consultant firm
helps us with that uh the blue line
represents uh their forecast from
october 2019.
uh you can see that fiscal year 20 was
going to be right about the 120
135 million level um it increased
um beyond 22 and about a little over a
percent
um a year um with covert
uh and we're taking they get they gave
us a low
estimated range mid-range and really
severe
so we've taken their mid-range um impact
and you can see fiscal year 20 um we're
roughly down almost 15 million dollars
um in total revenue from the previous
forecast
this week 21 down 23 million
and then fiscal year 22 uh 12 and 23
uh 10 million so in aggregate there
we're looking at a very significant
impact
over from fiscal year 20 to 24 we're
talking about a 71 million dollar
reduction
in total revenue from what was
previously forecasted
over this 10-year period we're looking
at 121 million lower than what was
previously forecasted
which is going to have an impact on the
the capital work uh on the turnpike
system we're going to see
potential delays anywhere from one to
two years on some of those capital
projects
um and we'll we'll be able to manage
that um but i just want to give the
committee um
just like a little bit of an insight
into how covert has impacted the channel
pack system
and certainly there's a similar impact
on the highway side
excuse me representative murray you have
a question
thank you very much um why
wouldn't the revenues rebound back to
pre-covert
is this uh indication that you think
telecommuting is going is basically a
thing to stay is here to say
yes so what this what they were basing
their uh projections on
was over lasting anywhere this this
this covert impact they're lasting
anywhere from three to six years
and then long term they feel
that this virtual work environment
is going to have an impact on um
the commute to what extent you know we
picked the mid-range you know certainly
on the lower end you know they're
thinking
it could be anywhere from you know one
day a week
to two days a week and if you really
think about that one
if one if everybody works from home one
day a week
that's a 20 reduction you know so
um long term they they're going to have
some
i mean some firms require people to go
back to the office full time
um and maybe have a maybe a more liberal
work from home
type of approach you're going to have
other firms that will allow people to
work from home
you know entirely so it is going to
change the landscape
i think of how traffic is going to
evolve
long term now what we're also seeing
um just very early is that there were
more local trips occurring
um so these trips really are more of the
long
commuting trips and that's what's
happening on the turnpike system that's
more of a commuter
and recreational um corridors
but i think people as they work from
home
yeah they're traveling more
maybe maybe as many miles maybe slightly
fewer miles but they're traveling
more locally and not necessarily on the
interstates and turnpike systems
while covet 19 has had some devastating
impacts on
individuals the explosion of technology
will have lasting benefits for everyone
so
we've in the transportation sector we're
talking about the four different types
of trips
there's the the commuting trips where
telework
is likely to continue
to be expanded beyond pre-covered levels
so as chris is saying you know
firms obviously they want to get people
back in the office
people are craving that human
interaction and especially
companies are trying to innovate you
need to have people
in the room together but it is highly
likely folks will be given more
flexibility
which is great for work-life balance
allowed to work from home to a greater
extent there's going to be some impact
but then i touched on it earlier there
is the expansion of telemedicine
and so certainly people will still be
traveling
to specialty hospitals for consultations
but maybe some of that follow-up care
can be done
locally and use telemedicine to
complement that
again terrific for the individuals and
the quality of the care they're
receiving
but travel will be different um you know
with higher ed
more and more online learning um that's
also going to have an impact on trips
um as it is we see significant changes
in travel patterns when the schools
are in session or not um and then the
last one of course is online shopping
um and the expansion of amazon and other
delivery services
where people aren't going to the stores
as much but the transportation network
is just as important for the movement of
the goods
to the individuals and so as chris
mentioned
this is a challenging time for our
transportation planners
we have to work very closely with
chambers of commerce and with major
employers to understand
how they're going to be doing business
going forward to know what those lasting
impacts are going to be
and what their transportation needs are
at the end of the day we're here to
provide the infrastructure to support
them
so we have to continue to listen to how
their business model might be changing
so that we can understand what the
longer term
needs are going to be so it's it's great
for the individual
um the explosive technology is certainly
um improving quality life and that's
what we're all about
but um it's challenging for us to
forecast
right now while we're still seeing
different behavior
because of the risks associated with
covet 19.
we can't discern how people are behaving
today is it truly
because of changes to to keep reducing
the spread and keep people safe
or are they permanent changes because
it's a more efficient way for them to do
business
representative petra you have a question
you're still muted
i guess all day doesn't work
very good uh thank you commissioner for
taking my question uh you guys do an
awesome job and uh
really appreciate that what's the status
of
93 is that we on budget and
when was the estimated completion date
and also exit 4 is the
pandemic having an effect on that
so the expansion project to widen from
salem to manchester
um that project was declared
substantially complete this fall
but we are working on some punchless
items and finalizing
the last few items but essentially that
contract
is and that project is complete
the other project the construction of
exit 4a has been delayed slightly
we were advancing that project as a
design build contract
in other words instead of going all the
way through final design
and then awarding the construction to a
contractor
we had advanced the plans to about the
30 design
stage and we were procuring a team to
finalize the design
and start construction somewhat
concurrently
in an effort to try and shorten the
overall project duration
unfortunately when we opened the bids on
that project the
prices came in much much higher than our
own dot
estimate there's some
modifications to the scope that we
believe we can make
to reduce risk for the contracting teams
and hopefully reduce the cost
but as a result we have made the
determination that is more
efficient and effective to advance this
as a traditional design
bid build project so we have just
procured
or selected a designer to work on the
final design
that effort will be starting shortly and
we hope to get that contract before
governor council this spring
and so we're going to be about
another year after that contract is
awarded from
being able to finish the first phase
so basically we're hoping to break
ground
in the spring of 2022 and um
that project we're very confident that
we can deliver it for
a cost that is much closer to what we
had estimated
and um that's what we've set to work
doing right now
and bill cass is on with us this morning
bill is there anything else you want to
add
no just uh just what you said that uh
again back to your initial
question representative peter yeah no
essentially the 93
widening is is complete exit 4a was
always a
you know separate uh project interchange
there
the one last uh thing that will be going
on there is a um
there is a restriping contract that is
technically part of the 93
project it's it is kind of a punchless
item as the
commissioner said so next this spring
you'll you will see um
you know some durable pavement markings
for the whole length of of 93
and some final punchless items fixing
some signs and stuff but
eventually it's all done
thank you very much
so there's no other questions next slide
so basically on the turnpike on the
turnpike side
um because of the covet impacts on
revenue
it really required uh roughly a seven
and a half percent or twelve and a half
million dollar budget reduction
in fiscal year 22 from from the 21
budget
that was primarily on the capital side
some of the capital work
got moved out fiscal year 23's budget is
fair
is flat fiscal year 22. there were no
additional prioritized needs
that were requested all the operation
maintenance debt service and r r
requirements have been funded
in the biennium um and overall as i
noted
um we have some um
large capital work that will will
require
um the delay of one to two years in
order to
have enough revenue coming in to fund
that work so
um that is a turnpike uh if there's any
any questions we can take them now in
the turnpike system
now certainly you know if there are any
questions that come up in the future
we'll be happy to answer them at a later
time
all right if there are any questions
i'll move on to that
question excuse me representative heath
has a question
thank you madam chair and and thank you
for taking my question
i remember when we did the last budget
cycle um
there were a lot of concerns i see here
you you've targeted um
operations maintenance depth service um
there are a lot of concerns about your
equipment
on the highway um i'm sorry on the
turnpike
does that continue or has um
that been addressed so on the turnpike
side the equipment
has always been funded at um
a reasonable level to to meet whatever
requirements the turnpike system needed
it's on the highway side that we have
issues on equipment
and i'll talk about that uh later on
thank you i always get them confused
thank you representative
go ahead chris
i'm also going to turn it over to uh to
marina talk about the highway fund
good morning uh madam chairman and the
members of the committee
um i'm going to talk to you and get into
a little more detail on the highway fund
just as a general overview the highway
fund
is not the dot and dot is not the
highway fund there is some misnomer that
we control the highway fund which we do
not
it is the fund which the unrestricted
revenue from the gas tax or road toll
and registration fees
are collected by the department of
safety
it's also the fund where our federal
construction program
our garvey bonds and tifio proceeds are
collected and go through here so that's
why you'll see
that municipal construction aid and
construction blue
section that includes all of our federal
construction reimbursements and the in
any of these bonds and tifia proceeds
it's the primary source for our
operating budget
highway fund revenue from the highway
fund is appropriated to
various agencies so not only does dot
have get
money to use from the highway fund but
the but
safety the judicial branch and justice
also received funds from the highway
fund
in fiscal year 2020 the actual
expenditures
when we break it down about 59 of the
highway fund
was appropriated to d.o.t or was
expensed by dot
26 percent to other agencies so that
includes
safety um and justice and 15
to municipalities so that's primarily
that 15 is the block grant
block grant aid distribution that by law
12 of the gross revenue that's received
is distributed to cities and towns
so and that 15 percent gets added to
dot's percentage when you see the budget
breakdown
for the i know some of you may be
familiar with
rsa 99b this is the requirement that the
highway fund
um not less than 73
is dedicated to dot dos not more than 26
and other fund and other agencies not
more than one percent
so um in the 2223 biennium
um it it looks like the the
rsa99b is met i'm not sure if it if it
needs to be in hb2 if it needs to be
suspended
in prior years it had there has been a
requirement for it to be suspended
because those percentages were not met
um
[Music]
mickey will obviously um verify the
percentages
uh my rough estimates based on what the
governor presented
was about 75 percent point three percent
will be d
is dot for the ben biennium safety is 24
and other agencies is 0.7 so
it appears that we're um meeting that
requirement for rsa 99b
um just but depending on changes that
are made
that um provision in the law
um has been suspended in the past and
could potentially need to be suspended
so next just an overview on
the highway fund revenue
so many of you are probably aware the
highway fund
over time has had several one-time
fixes the revenue has been declining in
the highway fund you can see
it was here at almost a 340 40 million
dollars a year
and now we're you know it's down to
about 250 to
254 million projected in the next budget
there were several one-time fixes if you
want to call them
to try to balance the highway fund over
the years
the first was this 30
registration surcharge back in 2010 and
2011.
that was uh repealed after 2011
so that was only a temporary two-year
revenue for that during that same period
um you know this was back in the
recession of 2009
2010 um where we had
you know significant decreases in
revenue and we also had a deficit
um of 50 million dollars in the highway
fund so
um we've had to so some of
these one-time fixes were done so one of
them is
this retro turnpike toll credit
the department was able to go back on
projects and
let me just clarify our federal program
requires a match so we have um generally
um it's an 80 federal funds
20 required state match the state
does not provide state
highway funds to match the federal
program
so therefore we use toll credits from
the turnpike system
to match that program so in essence it
makes
all of our projects 100 percent
federally funded
so it doesn't increase the pot of money
we get from the feds or anything like
that
it just makes all of our projects 100
percent federally funded
so um during that time frame back in
2010 11
12 we there was a look-back provision so
we went back to some projects that we
had used state funds to match and we
went back and we did we retroactively
took toll credits
to bring back that revenue into the
state
the next the next item down here was the
i-95
bridge sale so at one time the highway
owned that the i-95
bridge between maine and new hampshire
and that was sold to the turnpike system
to raise revenue for for the highway
fund it also made sense
um from a maintenance and operations
perspective because
there was a very small portion that was
highway and the
everything around it was all turnpike so
it did it did make sense but that sale
was for 120 million dollars it was
supposed to be paid off over a 20-year
period but because of the issues in the
highway fund
it was paid off over a six-year period
so you can see
um once the the payment of that note was
made
there's no more revenue coming into the
highway fund for that
um and then we have some miscellaneous
up here
um at one time our federal revenue
related to our overhead that we collect
on the federal program
was going into unrestricted that was
changed
and is now restricted and it covers
our operating expenditures for our
highway design
in several other areas some of our
bridge maintenance and traffic
areas that were previously
where we used highway funds unrestricted
highway funds for that so those have now
been
those federal funds are now restricted
and
cover a portion of our salaries and
benefits within the dot
um some other one-time revenue fixes
that you don't see here because they
um are have been restricted
um in fiscal year 16 and 17
um 8.3 million from the
sb 367 which was the 4.2 cent
gas road toll increase in 2014
prior to us finalizing the tiffy alone
8.3 million of that revenue
was dedicated to highway operations that
year to help balance the highway fund
so that was about 16 million over that
biennium
in fy 17 13.9 million was transferred
from the general fund
into the highway fund to balance it for
that biennium
for the um eight fiscal year 18 and 19
biennium
and then in fiscal year 20 for this
biennium four million dollars was
transferred for the from the general
fund to balance
the fy 2021 budget
and then currently in the fy 22
23 mostly in fi 22 we have the 41
million dollars from
the relief fund um that is assisting
um because of the lost revenue um and
there's also the 8.1 million
transfer from the general fund so as you
can see
over time we've had reduced revenue
we've had several one-time fixes that
keeps
kind of kicking the can kicking this
problem down the road we've been lucky
to be able to have
the general fund transfers and these
other things to help
balance the budget but you've seen from
some of the
you know the other slides with our
positions though because of these
reductions you know we've had
significant decreases in positions
almost
you know almost 200 positions um back in
that time
and then you'll see in some of the other
issues as
that the commissioner goes through later
with our equipment we've had you know
having
fur the maintenance on our equipment and
those type of things
representative petry you have a question
yes thank you and my all button works
right thanks for taking the question
is 93 coming in on budget and uh
the way we financed i believe
uh it was kind of unique could uh you
explain how that's going to work and
what the debt service is going to be
yes i-93 was um
the current budget was around 800
million and yes we're coming in under
budget
um for the benefit of the new members to
this committee
chris mentioned earlier both garvey as
well as tiffia
garvey is grant anticipation revenue
vehicles in other words
a federal bond that is backed by future
federal apportionment and tiffia
is the transportation infrastructure
finance innovation act
and that's actually a loan that was
backed by
the gas tax increase that was passed
that
re-referenced in sb 367
um so i'll let marie talk a little bit
more about the actual
funding for 93 but i just wanted to make
sure you understood that
that project was funded with both
federal bonds
as well as a federal loan the federal
bonds we pay the debt service with
future federal
highway dollars and then the loan we pay
with the state revenues coming in
through sb
367 the road toll or gas tax increase
so marie do you want to talk about the
the budget itself
yeah so for um for so for the tiffy
alone
um we were able to defer principal
payments
for nine years so we were able to defer
it while the project was in construction
and then an additional
five years so what we're doing right now
um is with that deferment of the
principal
the the revenue coming in is being put
towards road paving and bridges
maintenance in the rural parts of the
state
so we're putting about 10 to 12 million
dollars a year
towards paving and another eight million
towards uh bridge prop red list bridges
um once that we have to start paying
back the principal
which is in uh 20 2025
um then the paving
and the bridge work will not be we will
not be able to continue to do that
because those funds will be going
towards the principal payments
awesome thank you
any other questions related to that
yeah one if i may madam chair
i give my good go oh i'm on mute so yes
you're good to go
excuse me thank you um any no
any uh information or knowledge or
insight coming from ways and means
around
revenues for transportation
i believe safety has presented to them
and
as well as the governor's office on
their projections
so what you see in this slide
is what the governor has projected for
unrestricted revenue
for road toll and motor vehicle fees
so these are these are the projections
here the
um you know about 252 million 254
million
and i think that is still a decline much
like we showed you with the turnpike
system
there is still a decline there as
there's an anticipation that folks are
going to
continue to you know there'll be some
remote work telehealth all those other
um items the commissioner had brought up
so they don't quite get back to
um the levels that we were at before
um covid but i think they're but they're
gradually increasing
um each year so there hasn't been any
particular talk about
um how one might increase
revenues these are just the predictions
for now but any discussion about what
what they might be able to do
marie touched on some of the things that
are in the governor's budget
so she mentioned there's been a transfer
of general funds
into the highway fund that's associated
with
um when there was one time general fund
surplus
hb 1817 provided general fund
revenue to the dot for the completion of
some bridge projects
we had one project left to complete by
using those hb
18 17 we were able to switch the funding
to federal funds
and then the remaining 8 million has
been
put into the highway fund as part of
balancing the budget
in the governor's phase and so
the budget that you have been provided
is a balanced budget
we'll talk about our additional needs
but overall
while the highway fund revenue has been
flat in prior biennium and then was
certainly impacted by covid
um other sources of revenue have been
introduced to fund some of our
activities plus we talked about it
earlier we did receive that 41 million
in federal relief um that we have also
used to fund some of our operations so
typically federal highway dollars cannot
be used
but on this occasion it was 41 million
[Music]
with full flexibility and so that also
has taken the pressures off
but later on we'll show you what we can
and can't accomplish with this budget
but between the federal funds and the
general funds
everything is currently balanced despite
the challenges
and i i'm very empathetic to our own
state legislature
um the fast act the federal
authorization
transportation expires in
september it actually expired in
september
of 2020 but congress passed a one-year
extension
and also added funding into the highway
trust fund to make sure they could
fund all the commitments in that
one-year extension
congress will be debating how to fund
reauthorization
and they're seeing the same thing at the
federal level you know as fuel
efficiency increases
um revenues are declining through
traditional sources and then further
with over 19 and more limited travel
there has been a reduction in gas tax
receipts as well
so i know that the new hampshire
legislature
needs to understand how congress is
going to fund transportation to the
future to then understand what the gap
might be and what steps you might want
to take
but we're hopeful that through
reauthorization given
the pandemic and everything that it is
meant for transportation
that will be provided some more
flexibility as well as some additional
dollars
and i can appreciate our legislature
wanting to
to wait and see what money is provided
at the federal level
i'm just going to say so now i'll touch
upon the
highway fund budget um so beginning
um so the department was required
um to have a funding reduction of seven
percent
agency phase for fy22 and then
one percent increase to fy23 from the fy
22 level
um so as part of our reductions
uh we had to reduce our fleet equipment
we reduced that by
more than six million dollars a year uh
we had reduced our preventative
maintenance so
um unfortunately these were programs put
into the budget
new programs put into the budget um last
time in 2021
but with covid and you know
our need to try to conserve highway
funds
we did not move forward with these new
programs and therefore they were all
they have also been reduced
in the 2223 budget that includes our
bridgewat
bridge washing of about 1.7 million
dollars per year
guard rail repairs of about a million
dollars a year
tree trimming and brush clearing of a
little over a million
and then graffiti removal of about 200
000 a year
we also reduced temporary positions
over time etcetera you know engineering
intern program
uh marie representative petry has a
question
okay
ah let's see am i going here when
where'd it go
can you hear me okay all right uh the
ques the question is
uh i got a call from uh pittsburgh area
and uh a citizen was concerned that uh
the uh
i guess one of the maintenance people
had a two-wheel drive vehicle
and up in the north country that uh
could you explain that please
are we short with that short of money we
because it's
and i guess he asked the question
whether or not uh
why he had and they said it was enough
money to buy a four wheel drive vehicle
representative petrie if you don't mind
can we defer that question and we have a
slide and we're going to talk about
the fleet in more detail in a couple of
minutes okay very good
thank you let's circle back to that when
we get to that part of our presentation
appreciate your patience
um and so then as the commissioner and
chris
had um discussed before uh we received
41 million dollars in federal funding
um as part of the coronavirus response
and relief supplemental appropriation
act and this was used to displace
highway fund expenditures in fy
22. and then as was just discussed
earlier as well
hb 1817
for that one bridge project we do 8.1
million
of unspent appropriations um
is being uh lapsed and will be
transferred to the highway fund
um to manage this budget
um so additional needs that were funded
by the governor's office so we had some
um some areas
where that were short that we needed
funds for
so debt service was one of them
obviously we have prior
capital projects that have been approved
in hb 25
um so we needed to um be able to pay
debt service
on those prior commitments um so we got
about a three million dollar
increase from our additional leads by
the governor's office
and then um block grant um
had not been sufficiently funded based
on the revenue projections
so blocking it was also funded
appropriately appropriately based on
the revenue projections coming out of
the governor's office and safety
um we did one bit of good news
we did have uh 12 million dollars over
the biennium
for our winter maintenance um so this
funds
dot's winter maintenance at a three-year
average um
so as many of you remember in the past
um
you know we weren't even funded at a
three-year average and annually we would
come to the fiscal committee
um and need to request um additional
funds to be able to
um buy salt rent rent the equipment and
contractors and provide overtime to
folks so
this this um budget now funds it
at the three year average um it doesn't
mean we may never have to come back to
the fiscal committee again
but at least we're funded at a at a more
appropriate level
and only in extreme winters will we need
to come back and potentially ask for
additional funds
other some other smaller items that were
funded by the governor's office that
were additional needs
was related to doit
and that was for office 365
transfer to general services for
building maintenance to maintain
for the buildings here at dot transfer
to justice for
the ag's support of dot
and then the project development
engineering intern program was funded
at about four hundred thousand dollars
for the biennium so those were the
additional needs funded um during the
governor's phase
so we still have some additional
some other additional needs that were
not funded
the first is what we've been discussing
already is our fleet so we have about
6.4 million
per year 12.8 million over the biennium
um of an increase to to fund our
fleet equipment so that we can be at our
recommended replacement criteria
and chris uh we'll be going through that
um detailed information
to kind of show um that
the status of our fleet the wreck in the
recommended replacement criteria and how
far we're behind
in replacing our equipment we also
have some needs for bridge maintenance
in our traffic bureaus
for equipment with the deferred
purchases
um you know due to the coven reductions
these are important items that those
bureaus need to be able to continue to
do their work
and because we had to lapse those funds
in fy 20 some of those funds
you know they're behind again in their
some of their equipment purchases and
you know having to defer those items
related to the covid pandemic
uh preventative maintenance so um there
there these programs that we had to cut
that
as based you know based on the revenue
based on the
reductions we had in the governor's
agency phase
not the governor's the agency phase of
the budget sorry
so we still have we're still requesting
these additional needs we do believe
that
the guard rail maintenance and repairs
are extremely important
it's a safety issue and federal funds
are not eligible for maintenance and
repairs
in this area so we do have some federal
funds that we
when we're putting in new guard rail in
a project but we cannot
maintain and repair guard rail that may
be damaged with
federal funds so we we do have these
funds that we need and then there's the
bridge washing program
again um federal funds aren't you can't
use federal funds for
maintenance so the bridge washing
program
removes the salt and elements that
damage the bridge bridges
and it would allow um you know the
washing of the expensive more expensive
and larger tier one bridges annually
and to be able to do that preventative
maintenance and
hope and make the life of those bridges
last
a bit longer we have our
telematics devices equipment and
software for mechanical services
about 0.7 million over the biennium um
these are um two i you know these are
the telematics devices for
all the fleet equipment to be able to
monitor um
efficiencies for fuel and maintenance
location and that type of thing
you know we do believe that having these
the telematics will provide savings to
the department
um and something that we've had in our
budget now for several bienniums
but just it just hasn't been a priority
to get funded
the the next item are the its devices
repairs and maintenance and consultants
for our tismo bureau that's our
transportation systems and management
operations so those are the folks that
had um
monitor the traffic on all the highways
they have the
the cameras and the and the monitors to
be able to
regulate the traffic and know when their
accidents and be able to just
you know dispatch help
so over the um
past years we've had a significant
increase in the number of devices
so federal projects allow you to buy the
devices
and put them in to the corridors all
along i-93
turnpikes going up north 89 but as we're
increasing those devices
you know we had based on the tight
budgets we've had we haven't been able
to increase the the maintenance and
repair of those devices well some of
those now are getting old
they're starting to break more
frequently and so we need these
additional funds
to be able to maintain and repair um
again
just like the fleet you know we be able
to maintain and repair the the equipment
that we've put in our system
um and then we have the graffiti removal
that we identified that we had moved out
of the budget as well that's about 400
000 over the biennium
and then the last item is um
some of you may be aware some may not um
it's
um so fhwa law has a 10
20 year rule um so basically
um it's 10 years for engineering 20
years for right-of-way so
when you start a project and you spend
money in engineering
you have up to 10 years to move to the
right-of-way acquisition
or to construction and once you go to
right-of-way then you have it in
20 years before to get to construction
so the conway bypass project has not
gone to construction
um it was re the layout was recently
dissolved at gnc
um and the project's not part of the
10-year plan anymore
so because of that law fhwa has we have
spent
money on primarily the right-of-way and
acquisition of property
that will not be used for the conway
bypass so therefore we have to pay back
federal highway those funds
so this two million dollars per year
payback
um we have reserved some money for the
payback but we are still in need of
approximately
six to eight million dollars um of
funds to be able to pay back what
we think they're going to ask us for so
um this two million dollars per year of
additional needs
is to help um continue to put
funds aside to be able to pay back the
conway project
are there any questions on that or
uh marie yes this representative
berger i would like to ask you to give
me a call
so that we can have a longer discussion
on the uh
conway bypass because it's obviously
you know that it's right here in my
backyard
so i just i know that i knew that this
was coming i just need to
have a fuller understanding of uh
of what's going on so okay
okay thank you yes absolutely
okay are there any other questions if
not i'll turn it over to the
commissioner
um to discuss the issues and challenges
so as you've heard um several times this
morning
long term we are still concerned about
the health of the highway fund
and um the structural issues
but fortunately we did receive the
federal relief dollars and we're
optimistic that we'll get some
additional flexibility through
future federal actions um so it appears
that
with the cuts that we have made and the
work that we are deferring um
we can advance with
an adequate budget for this year but
there will be some of those looming
liabilities that we've discussed in the
past
our biggest concern still remains the
fleet
for the new committee members and chris
will do a deeper dive in a moment
but the replacement value of our fleet
is around
90 million so if trucks last
approximately 10 years we should be
spending around
8 to 9 million annually on vehicles
we have not been doing that for many
many years and we were
supported by the legislature and the
governor during the last budget
with both capital dollars to play catch
up and address our backlog of fleet
replacements
as well as a significant increase in our
operating budget
to start to invest at the appropriate
level unfortunately
and covet hits we did not move forward
with all of the purchases
as we had planned because of the revenue
uncertainty
and now in this budget we're back down
to the two to three million dollar per
year level
as opposed to the eight million dollar
level so chris will do the deeper dive
but that's still our biggest concern
overall
um but if there was some one-time
federal relief money provided to the
state
we would hope that we could use some of
that for fleet purchases
but of course it's too early to tell
what types of
stimulus or relief dollars may be
provided
and then as marie outlined is all of
these preventative maintenance items you
know whether it's keeping up with
guardrail
the graffiti removal these are things
that
we just unable to complete with our
current resources we're focused
on the assets that have the most value
i'm trying to maintain those and
unfortunately things like bridge washing
you know we're washing bridges every
other year
ideally we'd wash them annually but we
have to stretch the resources and do a
little bit of everything
with the budget that we have and then
the other challenge that's ongoing
especially in winter months
is in the southern sections of the state
as well as along the borders with
neighboring states there's a lot more
competition
for contractors so for winter
maintenance in particular
we are struggling at times to find
adequate contractors to complement
our dot staff if we have a mild winter
we don't use the contractors to the same
degree
and that's why we manage our programs
that way
in the higher elevations and the
northern parts of the state where we get
a lot more snowfall year to year
we have more of our own forces plowing
and treating the roadways
in the southern sections of the state we
rely more heavily on contractors so that
in the years when we have a mild winter
we're not incurring the costs of having
a large team
who aren't needed 100 of the time but
the downside is
you know we we need to be able to
attract and retain
those contractors to work alongside our
folks so that's still a concern
sorry go ahead okay uh commissioner
obviously
any money that was authorized in the
uh package that passed in
uh december has not been accounted for
in your budget is that correct
it was not accounted for in our agency
phase but the governor included those
dollars in our budget
and so there was activities that would
typically be funded
with highway fund revenue
and we're counting on that federal
revenue
to fund some of those aspects that's why
our draw on the highway fund is lower
in the first year of the biennium okay
so you he
in the governor's phase he has guessed
about how much
the um the latest act
the one that was passed in uh december
it's the 41 million marie can you go
back through the slides to the
um the bar chart that chris talked about
okay i i got the 41 million
and i just wanted to show you how the
stacks look um
okay oh here
um so you'll see in our agency phase
we were anticipating a draw of
216 million approximately on the highway
fund
when we received the 41 million in
relief dollars
our draw on the highway fund has been
reduced to 182 million
while our federal funding has been
increased from
207 to 248.5 so that's where the 41
million comes into
would have play highway funded to
federally funded
i'm trying to understand was the 41
million
based on the first cares act
no the the first cares act provided
nothing for
highways it was only support for
airports
and public transportation it was a bill
that was passed in december
um that has a much less
friendly acronym um bill that provided
the 41
41 million so in the agency phase we did
not
know that money was coming whereas now
we're in the governor's phase
um that 41 million was provided for
state dots
so that's how we were able to govern his
office and switch things out from
highway funded to federally funded
okay so all right thank you very much
and
we'll see what happens i appreciate that
very much
so that revenue is that federal funding
is certain that was provided in december
those dollars are are coming to the
state for the state deity
okay marie do you want to go back to
just so you know page 876
of the governor's budget is the county
that's the county unit 3007 it's our
highway maintenance bureau
and that's where you can see the 41
million of federal funds
has been appropriated and you can see
how it
that change um in the
41 million of federal funds all right
thank you marie i
i appreciate that i've i've just been
confused about
which money we were talking about
and i thank you you're welcome
and so the other item that was touched
on is you know in the short term
um we're taking the
revenue from sb 367 which was
the road toll or gas tax increase um and
we
are paying interest only on
the tiffy alone that was the loan for
i-93 the representative petrie asked
about
but eventually as marie explained we
start to pay the principal then we will
have less
capacity to do work on rural
roads and bridges many of
the sections of roadway that we're
paving with this revenue that's
available
in the near term these are roads that
are not typically eligible for federal
funds
um and part of the reason we secured the
loan and got such a
low rate was because we pledged to
stretch the value
of sb 367 and do the work
in these regions of the state where the
condition of the infrastructure really
warranted
more investment so we were very
fortunate
because of this program and because of
the legislature passing this bill
we're experiencing some of the best road
and bridge condition that we have
in a long long time but we just have
that concern
that once we start to pay principal on
the loan
then the condition will deteriorate
again because we just don't have the
capacity this is something we also are
advocating for at the federal level
for additional investment and more
flexibility
to do some work on the what they call
the off system the non-federal aid
eligible system
that will need to be addressed at some
point i do have a question
uh did 367 have
a time timeline
on it or is that did
yes when the um the loan for i-93 is
paid off
then the increase in the road toll or
gas tax sunsets
okay and what when are we projecting
that i'm sorry i know somebody said it
but i
20 34 isn't that correct me that's great
all right thank you very much
um so this ties into this next bullet
item which is the limited state funding
for non-fed eligible
roads and so
part of the reason that we ended up in
the situation
where we wanted to invest more is
because
hundred and forty miles of our roadway
network that is state-owned is not
eligible
for federal dollars um so sb 367 has
really
given us a lot of flexibility and with
the additional revenue we're paving
around 1800 miles in total
over the duration of the program
but longer term this is something
that we don't want to uh
sneak up on the legislature that you'd
have time to take action
um and prepare accordingly other items
on this slide we've also touched on
previously today um
as was mentioned our current vacancy
rate is around 15
that is our vacancy rate department wide
the timing of
uh covet 19 meant that some bureaus were
disproportionately impacted
for example we often hold some of our
vacancies in highway design
um so that we can recruit from recent
college graduates
in the um the springtime and of course
the hiring phase was implemented in
march
and so at one point our vacancy rate in
highway design was around 25 to 26
um with the hiring freeze now being
lifted and the governor's
22-23 budget um being finalized
we're starting to work to to backfill
some of those vacancies
other bureaus that were significantly
impacted um
support both our project development
activities as well as other areas of dot
so for example in the bureau of
right-of-way
certain work units and i've seen a 50
vacancy rate
um and then our office of federal
compliance
um they have seen vacancy rates in
excess of 60
so some of our very small bureaus um if
we only had you know
12 or 15 positions and circumstances
were such that we had a lot of vacancies
before the pandemic
um they have really been struggling to
keep up during this time
but the good news is and now that the
hiring freeze is lifted we're actively
working to recruit
but it will take us some time to catch
up a lot of the work that was deferred
just to limited resources um
other items up here at transit funding
you know we touched on it
typically the state does not provide a
lot of assistance to match federal
dollars
in the short term this is not a
challenge because at least on the
operating side
we can use the cares act federal funds
at 100
um but beyond this biennium that will
continue to be a challenge making sure
that we have
matching dollars to access federal
programs
and then the last two items retouched on
this the state match for the federal
highway program
and she explained the toll credit
program
and so basically uh the turnpike system
to explain how we actually accrue total
credits in the first place
because the turnpike system predates the
federal highway
i'm sorry the federal aid system and the
national highway system
um we have always collected our own
revenue to take care of those assets
we typically don't draw on federal funds
to maintain
the turnpike but those are
high volume roadways of critical
importance to
the movement of goods and people and so
every time we invest in our turnpike
system we
accrue credits with the federal
government now this is not cash
it's purely a credit and so marie
explained how we
leverage those credits to access federal
funds
and so for every keeping it in simple
terms you know for every eighty dollars
the federal government gives us
typically you bring twenty dollars of
cash match to the table
and you spend a hundred dollars and what
we do in new hampshire
is we spend the eighty dollars
and match it with twenty dollars of toll
credits
it's not real cash though it's just a
credit it's a way of accessing federal
money
so we only spend eighty dollars um so
this means that our programs are
proportionally much smaller
than our some of our neighboring states
which do
bring a cash match to access their
federal funds
beyond that new hampshire also receives
the least federal funding of all the
states
where transportation is concerned
something that our delegation is always
trying to work on and so
it means the size of our construction
program is smaller
than states of similar size with them
in some cases they have less lane miles
to manage than we do
um and so that's one of our challenges
the good news is we have very high
balances of troll credits
so when there's federal grants or at the
end of the year when there's federal
redistribution
and that's when they provide access to
additional federal dollars that have not
been spent
new hampshire is in a strong position we
don't have to come back to the
legislature and ask you for the state
match to be able to access those dollars
we know we have the toll credits and so
any grants that we're awarded
or redistribution that we get we can
immediately proceed to spend those
financial resources um so there are
pluses and minuses to the utilization
of total credits but overall
the one downside is that our program is
a little bit smaller
compared to other states and then the
last item is the state a bridge program
i receive emails from elected officials
all the time talking about municipally
owned
bridges that are in poor condition and
whether or not there's any state
assistance available
to help them either rehab or replace
that structure
unfortunately all we have available
is 6.8 million annually funded through
sb 367 to make those bridge improvements
at the municipal level
and so um that is something that we hear
frequently
is that that program um
the the towns are men are struggling to
maintain their own infrastructure and
they would
very much appreciate any additional
assistance from the state
um madam chair i think someone has their
hand raised
i don't know if um oh
there you are
okay i'm sorry
representative murray did you have a
question
don't know me i think it was
representative heath and then
representative
if that's helpful that's very helpful
i was off uh off camera here so
um representative heath do you want to
go ahead
yes please um thank you thank you for
taking
for um letting me ask a question madam
chair
um and thank you victoria um i want to
go back to
the free your free fleet under funding
now um i just want to make sure i have
this correct so
in your budget you requested eight
million dollars
um for your fleet um and you were
um in the governor's phase you were
given two million
is that correct no that's not correct
um we were given targets in the agency
phase
yeah and given the health of the highway
fund
the budget that we presented also
underfunded
the investment in the fleet because we
felt that there was other higher
priorities in terms of
investments that we should be making
knowing what the revenue outlook for the
highway fund was
the governor funded us at a similar
level to what we requested in our
agency budget however we know that's an
area of concern and where we should be
spending more money
but we agreed with the governor that
there are other investments that
we should be making before we increase
the funding for the fleet we wouldn't
want to increase the funding for
equipment
and vehicles at the expense of other
areas all right thank you
representative bucco you had a question
uh yes thank you madam chair
i want to thank the commissioners for
presenting today and
marie and kathy and um
on page 23 the the pages we were just on
you use a rather shocking term here it's
called structural insolvency
can you explain the effects of that
please
so when we talk about the highway fund
um
we're talking about the fact that there
is additional revenue beyond
what we're collecting from traditional
sources that's necessary to balance the
budget so marie showed you the slide
where we had the one-time fixes in prior
um biennium um this time around
uh we have has been said stated several
times you know the 41 million of relief
funding
as well as the transfer of the 8 million
of general funds to balance the budget
but at the end of the day you know even
before covet we know that people are
driving more fuel-efficient vehicles
and therefore even though they might
have been driving more pre-pandemic
our revenues were either fairly flat
or declining meanwhile the cost of doing
business goes up
and so this is something that they're
grappling with at the federal level
and you know will need to be addressed
at the state level
depending on what happens uh and how
quickly
there's wide adoption of electric
vehicles we're going to continue to see
erosion of revenue from traditional
sources and that's why there's a lot of
conversations about
how do we fund transportation into the
future
but each biennium we're coming up with
one-time solutions
um to make sure that we have a balanced
budget
and then longer term we still need to
find the right solution and something
that's acceptable
to the legislature but you're not alone
the congress is having exactly the same
debate
okay thank you
uh commissioner we have not
made any progress as far as i know
on changing the
electric vehicle
charges uh for using the roads is that
correct
um correct there's been several bills
that have come forward
um some of them were specifically
uh requiring electric vehicles to pay
more in vehicle registration as a way to
offset
the fact that they're not contributing
with what we call the road tool or are
paying gas tax at the state level
there's been other bills like
representative major his concept of a
road usage fee
that didn't just target electric
vehicles um but targeted
all of the vehicles that are higher fuel
efficiency hybrids as well as
um every every make and model on the
road today is much more fuel efficient
than it was
10 or 20 years ago um you know
personally
i used to drive an old ford explorer
that got about 11 12 miles per gallon
the models that you can buy today
get 25 miles to the gallon sometimes
even higher than that depending on the
nature of
the driving that you do um so it's the
the entire fleet that's on the road
today is just more fuel efficient
than the vehicles that previously were
contributing
and that's this is why it's so
challenging to think about a long-term
source of funding for transportation at
the federal level they've been talking
about you know tracking
vehicle miles traveled and it would be a
user fee you
pay per mile of the system that you
utilize and there's a lot of concerns
around privacy and how that data would
be
collected and audited and such um
and so that's why there hasn't been a
permanent solution but most
of the legislation has been been
proposed
here in new hampshire has been around a
registration surcharge type concept
either
targeting electric vehicles or a sliding
scale
where the registration would increase
as the fuel efficiency of your vehicle
increases um so you
it's not really looking at increasing
the investment the concept being
we're asking people to pay what they
would have paid before when they drove a
last fuel efficient vehicle
uh i don't there's nothing
in the legislature this year that i'm
aware of or is there
i don't believe there's any bills we
haven't been asked to provide fiscal
notes or
testify on any okay i didn't think so
all right thank you
um so the last item that we wanted to
talk about if there's no further
questions
um is that deeper dive into the fleet
and so at this point i'll turn it back
to chris
and he'll explain a little bit more
detail
what the deferred investment in
equipment means
and this is one of the areas where you
know our trucks have to run
um we have to plow the roads we need
that equipment to perform
our critical activities and so it's
always my concern
that when we don't replace vehicles in
the appropriate time frame
we spend a lot of money mandating them
and keeping them
road worthy and so in a way we throw
good money after bad
um and it causes a lot more headaches
for our team you know not only is it
stressful working long hours
in the winter and trying to keep the
roads clear but then when you have
equipment
um that breaks down and you're trying to
get that back
up and running that's just not only
um an expensive way to do things but
it's also extremely
burdensome on on the staff whose primary
focus is public safety and getting their
core work done
um so with that i'll let chris walk you
through the numbers that we have
up on the slide thank you commissioner
so
this slide and there's a lot of there's
a lot of information
on this slide um i'm going to try to
summarize it
and i'm sure there'll be a lot of
questions but each
at the end of each fiscal year
mechanical services bureau
compiles kind of this uh fleet
statistics and it's based
as of july 1st 2020 it takes into
account
what currently exists in terms of
all the trucks heavy equipment
passenger vehicles and so on um what
stage they're in
in terms of their life expectancy um and
then
which ones exceed the parameters that we
have in place so for example
you know our heavy trucks uh uh six
wheels and ten wheelers
um we expect them to last 12 to 15 years
and have roughly about 250 000 miles
light trucks like the half ton three
quarter ton
vehicles we expect them to last about
000 miles in about seven to ten years so
those are kind of the parameters we're
using so you can see on this chart
um we have the total number of units
about 1258 units that we have
and you can see in um in that column d
the number of units in each category so
for example we have 70
that are categorized as extra heavy duty
trucks those are uh
10 wheelers those are uh striper trucks
uh tractor trucks um bridge inspector
truck
um the tr the heavy duty trucks those
are
six wheelers those are pretty much uh
you know
the sun the the primary uh plow trucks
that we have those are our six
wheelers we have 260 units of those uh
medium duty those a
ton ton and a half trucks light duty
three-quarter half ton and so on
um associated equipment those are just
spreaders
that we have and probably the other big
piece is the mobile equipment
construction those are our graders and
loaders
so you can see the approximate
replacement value cost
of each one of those categories and
in column f the number that exceed the
life expectancy excuse me
the life age or usage parameter
so in total roughly 277
of the 1258 units exceeded
the parameters or 22 percent
in order to replace all that you can see
in column j
there's a replacement cost associated
with that and all the way down to the
bottom
that totals up to 33 million now this
was done
as at as of july 1st 2020
so since that time we have we still had
plan 20
and 21 acquisitions that were in various
stages
of being purchased and being put in
service
so that was actually 16 million dollars
so in essence
what i like to call our backlog is
roughly that 16.8 million
now i do want to say we have done you
know the legislature and the governor
working with the department
have has really done um you know great
in terms of providing some funding for
fleet over the last two bienniums
we had two capital budget items 10
million dollars in each biennium
that helped with addressing the backlog
and in the last biennium our fleet
was um i would say our fleet
was fully funded however because of
covert
we did have to look hard at that and we
did
lap some of those funds
we also received vw settlement funds for
our heavy equipment i believe
we received roughly 4 million a little
over 4 million for that
from that source of funding so we have
done well in the past
we are uh with with the current
uh budget my fear is we're gonna fall uh
behind again uh the two million dollars
certainly um is not enough to even
sustain
um the the vehicles that will
next year uh be beyond our
um our fleet parameters so in essence
we we've noted an 8.9 million is really
what our target level should be annually
to put towards fleet equipment
replacements
if we do not put that dollar forth then
we're going to fall behind
um
and i think you know to catch up over
time if we spread this out over five
years
just just addressing this backlog of
16.8 million
you know we would have to you know
provide
3.3 million over the 8.9 million
in order just to address the backlog and
get everything on
a sustainable schedule
so with that i know there was a question
relative to
um two-wheel pickups versus four-wheel
pickups in the north country
um i'll answer that and then answer you
know any other questions but
you know basically that four wheel drive
pickup trucks um costs probably three to
five thousand dollars more
than your two wheel pickup um if you
look at the 141 number and 173 number
that's how many um pickups that we have
half that's constantly quarter ton
um so it really
boils down to a standard and
if we look at that class of truck
if we convert all those two-wheel
pickups to four-wheel pickups
you know you mean you'll be looking at
probably needing another
um million and a half roughly in order
to do that
so we are we are evaluating the benefit
cost of that
you know certainly a four wheel drive
pickup costs uh more
upfront and more long term to maintain
we have an equipment needs committee
that will be looking much closer at that
i know there's a lot of foremen
that feel they need a four-wheel drive
pickup
but it has been a decision in the past
that too will
you know suffices when we look at the
cost
the overall cost of that category of the
fleet
um so with that i'll be happy to answer
any other questions
representative heath you had a question
yes
um i just want to go back to the 10
million that
was appropriated in the capital budget
um did i hear you say that some of those
funds were lapsed and they actually did
not go
toward the fleet nope um what i meant to
say
the the the capital funds did not lapse
we're still
working on drawing those funds down what
has lapsed is
in the last budget i think we had
roughly nine million dollars
in each year for fleet equipment some of
those
funds in 20 have lapsed and in 21
um they're not being expended
uh cu can you explain to me why
um just because of the situation with
the highway fund
um we were looking at you know essential
um purchases and at that time we were
um we were deeming that there were other
more important expenditures that were
necessary
and we needed to make sure that we
didn't run the highway fund into such a
negative state
that it was going to be difficult to
address that in this budget
and one final question if you don't mind
um i just need to go back to the the
fleet maintenance
you say that you need eight million
dollars a year
um but you only have two million dollars
a year
and this is the by not budgeting
eight million dollars a year it puts you
way behind
um can you just speak to that again um
because it sounds like there was enough
money
but it didn't have it it lapsed because
of the situation
i i just need more explanation please so
representative
traditionally we were underfunded for
equipment this is how we came to have a
significant backlog
so if you recall during the last budget
we were advocating for both capital
dollars
to play catch up on that backlog and
then for the first time in many many
years
you increased our budget so we could
replace vehicles
so that's what chris is referring to so
we had a capital budget item in hb 25
to address prior deferred replacements
and then you increase the funding in our
operating budget to around that nine
million dollars per year
so we could keep pace going forward and
start replacing vehicles at the right
frequency
but when covet hit and we knew that
there was nobody driving
which was absolutely necessary right to
stop the spread of covet 19 we
completely support why we had
stay-at-home orders and why then the
governor flexed things open
you know on a gradual basis but with the
revenue picture being so uncertain
there was a hiring freeze implemented
all of our capital purchases were frozen
because the last thing we wanted to do
was incur more debt and not having the
revenue to pay the debt service
in the next biennium and then in
addition we were asked to lapse as much
money as we could
to put us in a strong position for this
upcoming budget
and so that's what chris is referring to
we did not move forward with the capital
budget items because those were frozen
temporarily
that has been lifted now that we
understand you know what is budgeted for
debt service and the governor's budget
for 22 and 23
we're moving forward with some of our
capital budget items that were approved
last time around and then in addition
um we lapsed the majority of
um the funding that was provided in our
operating budget
that was associated with truck purchases
that we hadn't
initiated when clove it hit so
we did not replace the vehicles that we
had intended to replace
when you gave us that additional 18
million for the biennium
so that's what that's why it looks like
we didn't have the money we did
but then we didn't spend it it was
because of kovitch
we proceeded very cautiously and we
talked about
we tightened our belts and we focused on
core maintenance activities
so we did not make any large purchases
whether it was materials
or equipment we did a lot of more
traditional
preventative maintenance and smaller
scale projects this past year in
effort to save as much money as we could
another area you know
typically would have hired a lot of
seasonal help for things like line
striping
instead of bringing in seasonal workers
our highway maintenance crews
staffed and supported line striping
efforts
which then meant we were able to lapse
more money on the highway side
because we just we were very concerned
about the revenue outlook
and so for this budget i want to say
again you know in our agency phase
we too agree that we don't want to fund
the fleet at the expense of other areas
of department
and that's what you see in the
governor's budget but certainly if there
was to be more revenue
or one-time federal money where we had
flexibility on how we use it
the fleet is the first thing that we
would want to
to fund and replacing these trucks
will make us run more efficiently as a
department and take a lot of stress
off the employees who end up having to
work on these older vehicles all right
thank you it's just very frustrating um
to hear um we worked so hard to get you
those extra dollars
and then to hear that they weren't used
thank you
and none of us anticipated though the
financial situation that covered would
have put us in
so yeah we're sorry that that hard work
and the support that we saw from the
governor and the legislature you know we
weren't able to execute on the plan that
we developed together
representative bucco you have a question
yes i do thank you madam chair uh
commissioner um
i might be repeating what you've already
said but i want to be clear on what i'm
looking at on this page
mechanical services so it says
um current replacement needs are 33
million
and planned for 2021
is 16.2 million
leaving a a shortage of 16.8 million
is that correct first of all i guess
that is correct so those plan
fiscal year 20 and 21 acquisitions there
with a a capital b a capital budget
that was appropriated uh they are with
um
vw and
some of the some of the um monies
for equipment that were not lapsed
uh thank you i mean i have a follow-up
um
certainly um down
down in the bottom left-hand corner you
have catch-up time and
i so um to pay it off
to catch up in one year would be 16.7
million which is the total on the other
column or it's broken down into five
years and 10 years
um i i guess that's my question
well well the other question was you
need 8 million eight eight million
per year is what you what you should
have yeah so the key thank you
replacing vehicles at the appropriate
frequency you know our suggestion would
be to fund things at
that eight to nine million dollar mark
so that we'd be
taking vehicles off the road you know
the right time and not incurring all
this additional expense trying to keep
them running
while we very much love the federal
government to give us some
you know stimulus dollars or have access
to funding
to address the fleet and we would be
very concerned if we replaced all of the
vehicles at one time
because then 10 years from now or 12
years from now you'd have that looming
liability
that we'd have a lot of vehicles all
reaching the end of their
useful life around the same time um so
that's why we
show you some you know different um
time frames over which to address the
backlog
um so that you could invest a smaller
amount and not end up
you know a decade from now in a similar
situation
thank you uh representative lynn you
have a question
yes thank you uh madam chair um uh
you know i it i understand it sounds
like you have
challenges in a number of areas and i
completely understand that and
and i'm just wondering this last area of
the maintenance of the fleet
that you talked about it seems it seems
to me
is particularly critical i mean
especially in winter months for snow
plowing and stuff like that and
so i guess one of the things i'm just
wondering i know you mentioned that the
hiring freeze has now been lifted and
that you were talking about i think
earlier
um hiring certain personnel in uh
like for plan you know in that that do
things like planning new projects and
that kind of thing
and i don't mean to suggest for a minute
that i don't think that's important
but i'm just wondering in terms of sort
of ordering
priorities you know in what is a very
difficult time
if it since you don't have the people
that
you know the you don't have those hires
that you need
would it be better not to hire them to
put that off
you know for another year or even
another two years
and and do more to to upgrade the fleet
um so representative lin i think it
would be helpful
if i take some time to explain our
municipal aid and construction program
so we we really don't use a lot of
highway funds
to replace
and expand our infrastructure the
majority of the money that we're
spending in construction
is federal dollars or turnpike dollars
with some money going to
betterment projects and work on roadways
that aren't eligible for federal
assistance
but even in those categories a lot of
the money is coming from sb 367.
so it's pledged to that rural bridge in
paving we can't take that money and
spend it a different way
and that was one of the conditions of
the federal loan that we got we had to
pledge that revenue
and so what you're talking about is
deferring work
that isn't actually funded with highway
funds
all of the majority of our project
development activity and our
construction activity
is funded from the other sources and
those revenues are either state funds
that are restricted
or federal programs where we cannot use
the money for routine operations
and maintenance and so it's our
operations and maintenance that most
heavily draws
on the highway fund and when we talk
about
operations you know it's really our
people that
drive the trucks and do the work the
equipment
and then the materials that are
necessary you know for
either buying salt or in the summer
months it's you know buying
asphalt or pipe or whatever it is we're
using for
our routine work so um
that's the most challenging part about
transportation actually when we work on
the 10-year plan with your colleagues
in public works and highways we go
through all the colors of money and the
restrictions and how we can spend it
but really you know we're talking about
the unrestricted revenue
that's only funding our
operations activities and
we're making really tough decisions
that's why we get a lot of complaints
about things like mowing and litter
pickup and graffiti removal because
uh with the financial
health of the highway fund we're
focusing on
public safety first and foremost and
then you know state of good repair
and we get to all of the more aesthetic
things if and when the resource is
materialized
thank you very much i appreciate that
explanation
representative murray you have a
question thank you madam chair um
commissioner you may want to
answer this later i know we worked
really hard last time to try to
do some sort of a plan to help you get
out of this
this equipment morass and
if there's one best thing we can do for
you this round would it be to try to
come up with that six or eight
i guess if there's two million in there
the six million to try to get you back
on
track in terms of replacing equipment or
are there other things that you you know
what's the one best thing we can do for
you in this
uh in this budget round and there's a
reason we finished with
this equipment slide if there was either
one-time federal revenue that comes in
the next
several months if there's a stimulus
package passed by congress
or there's any general funds or other
sources of revenue available
then we know exactly where we put it it
would be to fund
the replacement of vehicles i think
we'll give it our best shot
but we appr we would not as i keep
saying in our own agency phase
we did not fund the equipment at a
higher level than the governor did
because
we would not want to see cuts elsewhere
because you're talking about limiting
our capacity to perform the work you
know we need
all three we need people equipment and
materials
are there any further questions from the
committee okay
seeing none um we truly appreciate your
um openness and uh
all of the things that you have uh
brought to us today
and um just so that
you know we will be scheduling something
next week to um i'm not sure which day
at this point but to do a uh
a deeper dive into
the um finances
of the highway fund and
so really i i appreciate this very very
much
and uh and thank you all for
coming uh for the committee
uh we will meet again
at one o'clock
to uh tackle safety and
so two two big
uh areas today that uh that we're
looking at so
again thank you and uh we'll see you
back at one
thank o'clock thank you madam chair
thank you members of the committee thank
you
all right
uh mickey uh yes representative
yeah um it seemed to me
from a meeting i was at earlier today
that we can sort of um shut down
until um
and then i'll just fire it up as if it
was at 10 o'clock today brand new so
just click on the same link to get in
okay and uh we are now in recess
until one o'clock
thank you all we'll see you then all
right